you
hi everyone it's Jerry the Siberian trap
is a trap for black out of the Sicilian
defense Smith more gambit for to work
black needs both knights and queen to
directly or indirectly influence the h2
square here's how it works after E for
c5 d for C takes D and with c3 the Smith
more gambit black accepts this white
recaptures and now the queen Knight gets
involved Knight f3 d6 guards against
Knight d5 as well as paves the way for
Bishop c5 move I will show one line
where the bishop wants to put pressure
on f2 Bishop c4 the Queen gets involved
white castles the King Knight gets
involved and after Queen e2 Knight G for
the trap has already been set this setup
by the way for white for someone who
plays the Smith more gambit is very
typical namely the Knights being
developed classically the bishop on c4
the Queen playing out to e2 to vacate
the d1 square for the rook and there
might be now a temptation to just get
rid of this night with h3 however it's a
serious blunder because of the Siberian
trap Knight d4 the tactic of deflection
it's a sad story in all variations for
white taking the knight leads to mate
the Queen is hit if she doesn't move
she's taken if she does move we have
Maine tonight takes Knight with check
and yet again made on h2 however you
slice it if it does get to this position
right here after h3 it will be either
the queen or king that is 1 after Knight
d4 one additional line might run as
follows instead of h3 if white still
runs with the typical move rook d1 will
now follows Bishop c5 converging on f2
and there's not really a better move
than something like Bishop to e3 but
it's a sad story still for white because
structurally these guys are just
terrible isolated epon right here double
isolated e pawns White is still down
upon
has the bishop pair as well as this be
five squared to rely upon four pieces
for the remainder of the game one last
line to be aware of is at this point
instead of h3 or up d1 if Knight b5
hitting the Queen and defending against
the Siberian trap with Knight d4 the
queen can calmly play back to b8 still
keeping close eye on h2 and if now h3
the knight need not go anywhere because
if one trap is not enough
the Siberian with Knight d4 another one
now springs to life the fishing pole and
not to mention this Knight on b5 is
unstable at any moment
a six can be played the knight can be
kicked away from the defense of d4 and
we could see the Siberian trap with
Knight d4 the deflection hitting the
Queen in the night or of course if pawn
takes Knight the pawn recapture is
hitting the knight and if the knight
moves yet again making happen in a blink
on h2
you